(music)
- This is definitely the
sort of seat of thanks
and so I want to echo
some of the thank-yous
that were made earlier. To
the Lewis Walpole library
for being utterly
formative in my second book
and it's a kind of ongoing relationship
for which I'm very grateful.
I especially want to thank Cindy
for asking me to direct
"The Mysterious Mother."
While I have a few 18th
century restoration comedies
under my belt, I had never
tried my hand at tragedy
and she both trusted me with it
and kind of talked me into it
and I'm so so glad you did.
I also want to do one other thank you
for someone who has been
for me in this project
behind the scenes and a huge
help and that's Joe Roach.
Joe challenged me about seven years ago
to do The Scholarship of Performance
and it was one of those suggestions
that was utterly transformative
for my professional life
and my intellectual life
and my students lives.
So I just want to thank you for that Joe.
It's definitely enhanced
my ongoing love affair
with the 18th century.
All right well when we started rehearsals
for "The Mysterious Mother" lo
these many three days ago,
the first thing I said to the cast
is "the only way out of
this play is over the top."
We were faced with a less than 48-hour
start to finish process
and a play that is genuinely interesting
and so that over-the-top
has played itself out
in a few different ways.
For those of you who
weren't in on the secret,
the two evil priests were
played by an actual priest
and a Catholic theologian.
We also went to some
pains mostly Cindy's pains
to try to reproduce the
Beauclerk illustrations
in our lavish costuming which included
a little gift from the universe
when we got Florian's costume back;
that beautiful purple costume.
We were told it was insured for extra
and it's a very beautiful costume
because it was worn by a famous person.
When he took it off the
rack and looked in the tag,
it said Mr. Lane.
It was worn by Nathan
Lane sometime in the 70s.
So everything here is over-the-top.
Even the Nathan Lane
connection. And finally
it felt over the top or
puckish or downright heretical
to be projecting images
of this Gothic castle
on Louis Kahn's clean, modernist wall
and see it works so well.
So the cast has already
been working on the musical.
We rehearsed "Mama Mia"
last night after the show
and we have a social media campaign
it's #Who'syourdaddy.
So this panel is about
"Staging 'The Mysterious Mother'"
and in the process that
we just went through
I think we experienced
some of the negotiations
that earlier panelists
have already talked about.
Our first negotiation
was sort of with the seen
and the unseen in this play
and that's reflected in
the way we were negotiating
David's brilliant cutback
with the original text
and the things that we could
not play but tried to show you
or let you hear.
We also were I think always
negotiating that line
between camp and tragedy
which turned out to be
a really productive
space and we found things
that we didn't expect to find.
So we hope that that inquiry
will continue with these papers.
So first we will hear from Marcie Frank.
Marcie is a professor of
English at Concordia in Montreal
and she teaches mainly
18th century literature.
She's finishing a book, "The Novel Stage
from the Comedy of Manners to Melodrama
which is about the ways
that theatrical conventions
shaped the novel between the
restoration and Jane Austen.
Her most recent essay, on
contemporary American queer writer
Dennis Cooper, "Cooper's Queer Objects,"
--now I have to go read this now--
can be read in the
current issue of "Angelica."
(mumbles)
Alright that's my bid and the
title of her talk today is
"'Wilful Walpole: Performing Publication
in 'The Mysterious Mother'."
- Hi and thanks for coming
and thanks for having me
to Jonathan Kramnik and Jill Campbell
and I'm delighted to be here
to share my work with you
and I really enjoyed the staging
and we'll see what you think about this.
The mystery of the Countess of Narbonne,
the mysterious mother
for whom Horace Walpole's
gothic tragedy is named,
is established at the outset
of the play by elaborate,
varied and even contradictory
discussion of her motivations
before she appears.
The porter describes her virtuous piety
and the priests Martin and Benedict
discuss her proud secrecy.
If her self-reliant despair
gives her some dignity
when she first comes on
stage at the end of Act one,
Florian's reflections on her
treatment of her son Edmund
at the beginning of Act two,
complicate without rendering
comprehensible her character.
He even depicts her mourning
the death of her husband
as hypocritical, "sable
chambers, the winking lamp,
the pomp of midnight woe"
are but a specious theatre
on which th'inconstant mind with decency
forgets its inward tribute."
Language that resonates
with "The Castle of Otranto"
introduces his ironic question.
"Who can doubt the love
which to a father's shade
devotes the son?"
The answer "The Mysterious Mother"
who has banished that son and determined
that he can only enjoy
his inheritance from afar.
Holy shades of Hamlet Batman
for Florian, Edmund's Robin the male line
has been interrupted by
the excessive performance
a female grief set in a specious theater.
The mystery of "The Mysterious
Mother" is sustained
until the play's end when the
countess reveals to Edmund
that his marriage to
Adeliza is incestuous
not only because she is his sister
but also because she is his daughter,
the offspring of a sexual encounter,
he unbeknownst to himself had
enjoyed with his own mother
who disguised herself
as his beloved Beatrice
on the very night of her husband's death.
The countess then kills herself.
Though she initially inspires
pity and Martin and Benedict
who schemed to acquire her
property for the church,
invite skeptical distrust,
when her crime is revealed
in "A moment" as Walpole himself
described it in the PostScript.
"A most odious moment
of depraved imagination"
the play is evacuated
of any internal ground
of moral judgment for the dark reversal
does not restore the
respectability of the church.
Walpole knew that the double incest
would render the play unperformable
yet he nevertheless
adapted it to the scene.
He exhibited a similar
ambivalence about its publication.
Today I want to suggest
that the specious theater
of "The Mysterious Mother"
with its ambiguous relation to performance
and it's strange publication history
provides us with the template
for Walpole's other endeavors.
Walpole recognized that the suppression
of the countess's secret
was essential to the
whole design of the play.
As he observed in the PostScript
for the addition of 50
he initially printed at
Strawberry Hill in 1768
in order "To palliate the crime
"and raise the character of the criminal,
"the audience must be
prejudiced in her favor.
"For this reason," he further explained,
"I suppress the story till the last scene
"and bestowed every ornament
of sense unbigoted piety,
"an interesting contrition
on the character
"that was at last to raise
Universal indignation."
Singling out some features of the play
for critical appreciation,
"Terror and pity naturally
arise from the subject,
"the moral is just and it conforms
"to the three neoclassical unities,"
he nevertheless distinguished his desire
"of striking a little
out of the common road
to introduce some novelty on to our stage."
He risked the disgust he
knew the play would provoke
and though he apologized for it,
he also implied it was justified
for the introduction of the new character
of the Mysterious Mother.
He echoed these thoughts
in "Thoughts on Tragedy"
composed in 1775 but only published
in the posthumous complete works of 1798.
The thoughts take the
form of three letters
to Robert Jephson who's
play "The Count of Narbonne"
was a successful adaptation
of "The Castle of Otranto"
that as its title suggests amalgamated
elements of "The Mysterious Mother."
It premiered in 1781 and was
performed 37 times up to 1798.
"If there is any merit in my play,
"I think it is in interrupting
the spectators fathoming
"the whole story till the
last and in making every scene
"tend to advance the catastrophe."
Exhibiting a self-consciousness
about his strengths and
weaknesses as a playwright,
Walpole remarked on his
attraction to the topic of incest
and passed on a story idea
for one of his favorite
subjects, Don Carlos.
As Walpole explained to Jephson,
"Why I gave up this fruitful canvas
"was merely because the
passion is incestuous
"as is most unfortunately
that of my Mysterious Mother
"though at different points
in time and that of Carlos
"a pardonable and not disgusting one,
"I shall rejoice at having
left it if you will adopt it."
Suggesting that Jephson
adopt a story less
controversial than his own, Walpole here
encouraged his protégé by his own example.
Evidently Walpole relished his
provocative effects on others
and here I'm going to recapitulate
some of the publication history
that we heard about
from Dale this morning.
In the short preface he wrote
for the edition of the play,
he let Dodsley print in London in 1781
which he claimed to be
publishing only to prevent piracy
Walpole again warded
off blame with apology.
"He cannot be more blamed
than he blames himself
"for having undertaken
so disagreeable a story
"and for hazarding the publicity
"by letting it go out of his hands"
Peter Sabor has observed
that Walpole's vexed attitude
toward publication is
taken to a compulsive level
with "The Mysterious Mother."
He desired to circulate in
print and to withhold himself
from such circulation by means of which
he could control critical response.
The preface to Dodsley's edition
is dated April 29, 1781.
Two letters of later
that year, one to Conway
dated May 28th and the other
two Mason dated July 3rd
indicate that though notice of publication
prevented the spurious
edition, it went ahead anyways.
Walpole however retained the edition
and circulated copies to friends
as he had also done with the 1768 edition
printed at Strawberry Hill.
Jephson's "The Count of Narbonne"
was printed by Thomas Cadell
right after its premiere
with the dedication
from Jephson to Walpole
dated November 17th, 1781.
I'm here floating a speculation
that even though Walpole
didn't say so himself,
perhaps he sought to coordinate
the printing of his own tragedy
with the performance of Jephson's play.
He was involved with Jephson's
production in other ways
including having loaned Alfonso's armor.
Even though he didn't circulate
the publication of the play,
he may have wanted to have
some printed copies available
to restimulate interest in coordination
with the production of Jephson's play.
Walpole was right to be concerned
about the reactions
his play would produce.
Francis Burney recorded her disgust
upon the discovery of
the countess's secret
when she participated in a
closeted reading of the play.
She felt "A sort of indignant aversion
"rise fast and warm in my mind
"against the willful author
of a story so horrible.
"All the entertainment
and pleasure I received
"from Mr. Walpole seemed
extinguished by his lecture."
Burney's strong response
as her narrative of her
reading experience shows
derives from our initial
enjoyment of the play
and the interest it elicited
in the character of the countess.
Her indignant aversion bespeaks
a betrayal of expectations
which she directs against the
"Willful author of a story so horrible."
Both Walpole's consistent
reflections on the disgust
the play must induce and Burney's response
indicate that the play's
streamline structure
was integral to its design.
It's smooth acceleration
made its ultimate revelation
all the more offensive.
Though many critics understand
Walpole's native English
gothic to be opposed
to a neoclassicism
associated with the French,
Walpole who's francophilia is complex
but there demonstrates a
strategic neoclassicism
that serves to manage innovation
while maintaining audience appeal.
In the PostScript he
minimized his investment
in critical approbation of the play,
for abiding by the rules
even though he himself
introduced those features for appraise.
"If the critics be pleased
that this conformity
"to their laws with this
conformity to their laws,
"I shall be glad to
have their satisfaction
"though for my own part I set
little value on such merit
"which was accidental and at best mechanic
"and of a subordinate kind
and were apt to produce
"improbable situations that remove them."
So this sort of typical double gesture
that lets him praise himself
and then not take it away.
An ideal venue for self-expression
and the manipulation of
response in many respects,
"The Mysterious Mother" occasioned
an emblematic performance
of Walpole's authorship.
Theater pervaded Walpole's authorship
can be seen across his writing.
The Castle of Otranto entered the world
as Walpole's production
under Shakespeare's mantle
and Marshall Brown has described it as
"a formal transmutation
of restoration tragedy."
00:14:28,037 --> 00:14:32,860
Walpole's treatment of his 1773
comedy, Nature Will Prevail
mirrors that of his tragedy.
He sent it to George
Colman at Covent Garden
who "Pressed to have it enlarged"
but then as the short notes
on the life of Horatio Walpole record,
he "Would not take the trouble to do so
"for so slight and
extemporary a performance."
Earlier in his career and
Dale also talked about
these forays into a
theatrical composition,
he had written "The Dear
Witches," a political pamphlet
in dramatic form that parodies
the witches scene in Macbeth.
It was laid out with a
list of dramatis personae,
five scene divisions and
scene and stage directions
when it was published in the
Whig journal "Old England."
He also enjoyed his own
capacity to produce disgust
in tale four of the
Hieroglyphic Tales for example
in which the Archbishop of
Tuum drinks an aborted fetus
he had mistaken for a peach in brandy.
Critics have long agreed
that Walpole's oeuvre
exhibits a remarkable consistency
across genres and media
including architecture,
gardening and collecting
which has led to psycho
biographical reflections
and disquisitions on taste.
Recently Sean Silver has
proposed that the design of
and writing about the
villa at Strawberry Hill
are emblematic of Walpole's
understanding of history.
Proposing that the villa
served as a sort of
enlarged wunderkammer, Silver
turns into the experiences
Walpole sought to supply his visitors
though he doesn't bring
out the connections between
historiography as a grand
house tour and the theater.
Building on Silver's account, James Lilley
brilliantly grasps the
effective intensities
and strenuous demands of
Walpole's double conception
of uniquity as collectible.
The singularity with no
intrinsic value that is common
and may even have been
produced more than once
as in an old Roman shoe whose worth
is independent of its former
wearer and the rare curiosity
of a monstrous birth.
Both operate on the margins of the market
remaining collectible only
to the discerning eye.
The specious theater of
"The Mysterious Mother"
conforms to both aspects of uniquity.
Depicting the suspension
of the patrilineal lines
so that the disgusting
generativity of the maternal
can be revealed and then expunged,
the play's subject matter
is monstrous birth.
Unperformable and yet in
intermittent circulation,
the play's singularity is redoubled,
guaranteed by its appearances in print.
As "The Mysterious Mother"
brings out more clearly
than any other example, "Wilful
Walpole" enjoyed provoking
and amusing his coterie and
then sought to extend the circle
to strangers, provided that they prove
their eligibility for mentorship
by withstanding his tests,
tests that included their
capacity to enjoy disgust
and to admire triviality.
(applause)
- Thank you so much for that paper Marcie.
Our second speaker will be Jean Marsden
who's a professor of English
at the University of Connecticut.
She's the author of
several books including
"The Reimagined Text,
Shakespeare Adaptation,
an 18th century literary
theory," "Fatal Desire,
Women's Sexuality in the English Stage"
and "Theaters of Feeling,
Affect and Performance
on the 18th Century Stage."
This last one forthcoming,
here be notified.
She is also the associate editor
of the works of Anne Finch
as well as numerous
articles on restoration
and 18th century theater.
Her title today is "Family
Dramas, 'The Mysterious Mother'
and the 18th century incest play."
- So thank you and
thank you for letting me
be a part of this even though
I'm not really a Walpoleian.
A guilt ravaged woman agonizes
about a crime she committed 16 years ago
when she took the place of a maid
who had arranged a tryst with her son.
As the result of this liaison,
she becomes pregnant and
gives birth to a daughter.
Claiming that the girl is an orphan,
she raises her until she at the age of 16
when her banished son returns home,
sees the beautiful girl and marries her.
Consternation occurs and
the woman stabs herself
in a fit of frenzy.
Sound familiar?
What I've just described as
the plot of "The Fatal Discovery,
or, Love in Ruins, an anonymous
late 17th century tragedy."
Despite these similarities,
I do not mean to claim
that the fatal discoveries,
the source for Walpole's play
he claims that he got the
idea from a real-life event
although the advertisement
for the 1791 Dublin Edition
does refer to this
contemptible performance
as a means of praising
Walpole's greater delicacy
in keeping his play off the public stage.
Rather my interest today
lies and considering
"The Mysterious Mother" in the
context of three other plays
that like "The Fatal
Discovery" deal with incest
as the crisis point for the tragedy.
Unlike "The Fatal
Discovery," all three plays
were successful in their own time
and were staged well
into the 18th century.
The first two plays I want to consider,
focus on brother-sister incest
and represent the horror it visits
on the unwilling participants.
The first is the most
popular of all restoration
in 18-century incest plays,
Thomas Otways "The Orphan"
in which Polydore takes
his brother's place in bed
with Monaimia the titular orphan.
And here we get echoes of
orphaning from paper this morning.
What Polydore thought was
simply an illicit assignation
was actually Castalio's and
Monimia's wedding night,
making this bed trick an act
however unwitting of incest.
Brother with sister-in-law.
Once discovered both
participants recognized the act
as a pollution that can never be removed.
It is a horrid deed that
results in the suicide
of both participants as well as
the sinned against, Castalio.
A more involved but less
catastrophic example
occurs in Dryden's "Don Sebastian"
in which the hero weds his half-sister,
a relationship the two
discover after the fact.
In doing so, they ignore
repeated wet warnings
and admonitions from other characters
as well as prophecies from the past
and in this it's reminiscent
of the greatest of all incest
plays Sophocles Oedipus,
a play that was adapted by Dryden and Lee
more than a decade earlier.
Sebastian and his bride, Almeyda
consummate their marriage
before the relationship is known
but unlike the orphans bloody
conclusion, they separate.
Almeyda to a distant convent
and Sebastian to a desert hermitage,
a fate similar to Walpole's
Edward and Adeliza.
Walpole's two innocent sinners.
These plays deal with
brother-sister incest
and while they are reminiscent
of the Edward Adeliza
storyline and "The Mysterious Mother"
they have little in common
with a central focus
of Walpole's play.
The countess and the
act that torments her.
A greater interest here is Edmund Smith's,
Phaedra and Hippolytus, a
play originally staged in 1707
with an all-star cast
including Thomas Betterton,
Elizabeth Barry and Ann Oldfield.
Smith's play went
through multiple editions
and remained in the repertoire
through the end of the 18th century.
Smith was a Greek scholar
and David Erskine Baker
describes Phaedra and
Hippolytus as a scholar's play.
The play has several interesting parallels
to "The Mysterious Mother."
The most obvious of these
is the nature of the incestuous desire.
Mother for son in this case, a stepson.
Although Phaedra's incestuous
desires are never acted upon,
the fact that she desires Hippolytus
while considering him
her son is made clear.
She describes her feelings
as a beastial passion
while stressing the exact
nature of her sinful desire
and exclaiming near the
beginning of the play,
"Oh can you keep it from
yourselves unknow it
"or do you think I'm so gone
in guilt that I can see,
"bear the looks the eyes of one who knows
"my black detested crimes.
"Who knows that Phaedra loves her son."
There is no secondary incest
in Phaedra and Hippolytus
and we discover early in the first act
the nature of Phaedra's sin.
Phaedra and Hippolytus opens with Lycon,
a scheming Minister of State
who much like Walpole's
Benedict plots throughout
to destroy the play's heroine.
Smith's character however is
more successful than Benedict
in prompting his victim
to confess her sin
and under the guise of wise counsel,
he uses it to torment her further,
urging her at one point
to yield to her husband
Theseus's desires, advice that she regards
with horror exclaiming,
"In the father's arms,
"Oh horrid thought, oh execrable incest.
"Even in the father's arms embrace the son
and this rather lurid passage was omitted
from the Bells edition in 1777.
In the end she, like the
countess, stabs herself
in a fit of guilt-ridden frenzy.
While Smith's play was
generally praised by critics,
some took offense with
Phaedra's willingness
to confess her crime in
front of an audience.
Seeing the event of her speech as an act
almost as grotesque as the
incestuous desire itself.
Even Dryden's Norma Hall in "Aureng-zebe"
as Charles Gildon notes, kept
"her brutal passion to herself
"not like the bolder Phaedra,
"making confidants and
breathing her incestuous desires
"in the face of a whole court."
Having incestuous desires is bad enough.
Articulating these desires to others
constitutes an even greater sin.
Walpole himself stressed the
illogic if not the sinfulness
of having a character discuss her sin
in front of an audience.
Digressing from a discussion
of [indistinct] to state,
"With all the difference of Grecian,
"French and English manners
it is impossible to conceive
"that Phaedra trusted
her incestuous passions
"or Medea her murderous revenge
"to a whole troupe of attendants."
While Walpole does not comment directly
on the criminality of Phaedra
herself, his linking of her
with the notorious villainous
Medea is suggestive.
As of now I have found no definitive proof
that Walpole new Smith's
play but I feel certain
that he was familiar with it.
Now I do not mean by
drawing these connections
to suggest that "The Mysterious Mother"
is just really a pastiche
of tropes commonly found
in earlier plays. Rather
examining the places
where it diverges from the norms
seen in other publicly staged plays,
illuminates the uniqueness
of Walpole's tragedy.
Uniqueness that I would argue
would have prevented it
from being stageable drama
at least in the 18th century since we know
from last night's performance
that we were able to stage it in the 21st.
To do so I would like to turn
back to "The Fatal Discovery"
that contemptible
performance with the plot
that so carefully parallels,
so closely parallels
that of "The Mysterious Mother."
Bad though this play may be,
it nevertheless possessed
qualities that allowed it
to appear on the stage.
Something that would have been
impossible for Walpole's play
no matter how carefully he worked
to engage sympathy for his heroine.
The most notable differences
occur early on in the play.
In "The Fatal Discovery,"
Beringaria the countess figure
does not knowingly sleep with her son
rather she thought she was arranging
to sleep with her husband
who had abandoned her bed.
As her confidant, Arapsia later explains
the convoluted chain of
events to Baron Cornaro's son.
The night before you were sent to travel,
you passed an engagement
with a young and foolish
maid of the house to meet that night.
Your father had made
another such appointment
which was by one discovered to your mother
and my unhappy lady in her stead
resolved to meet her
husband but by accident
she did mistake the room and
came to you but in the morning,
slipping from her husband as she believed
for fear of discovery she met my lord
just come from his intrigue
and then she found too late
her fatal error.
Like Phaedra, Beringaria
has confessed her guilt
to a trusted confidant but in her case,
the confidant taking on
the role of the playwright
can remind Beringaria and the audience
that her act was no more
than a fatal accident,
possibly even condoned by heaven.
Beringaria considers the
real source of her guilt
to be her own wanton love for her husband.
She should have considered
his desires, not her own
and allowed him to continue
with his adulterous behavior.
Her act while not appropriately
wifely and submissive,
was nothing more than an accident.
Destructive yes but unintentional.
By contrast, Walpole's heroine
is not the victim of a fatal
error in household geography,
something that distinguishes
her from her predecessor.
Because of this Walpole explains,
he felt the need to palliate the crime
first by creating the figure
of the evil monk, Benedict
and then by creating a
situation in which the countess
was to be imagined as thrown off her guard
by a combination of
grief and disappointment.
Her fondness for her husband
was thus in some measure
the cause of her guilt.
If the countess's act was deliberate,
even if it was not premeditated.
She explains that in the moment
when she waited longingly
for her husband's return,
I mean some of these lines
should be familiar from
last night's performance.
She saw him, presented a
bloody course before me.
"I raved.
This storm of disappointed
passions assailed my reason,
fevered all my blood." And at that moment,
she learns of Edmund's
proposition to the maid.
"Thou canst not harbor
a foreboding thought,
more dire than I conceived I executed.
Guilt rushed into my soul,
my fancy saw thee thy father's image.
Grief, disappointment, opportunity
raise such a tumult in my madding blood
I took the damsel's place."
This was no accident.
No case of mistaken identity.
While the countess's raw grief born out
of her love for her husband
may be a mitigating factor,
there is no doubt she
knew what she was doing
even if she could not foresee
the consequences of her crime.
This deliberate behavior,
this articulated fact of
incestuous desire is what I suggest
would have made "The
Mysterious Mother" unstageable,
a fact that while Walpole's
friend, William Mason
as we were just discussing implies
when he suggested a very few alterations
that he thought would make
the play more stageable.
After praising the play he comments
that there is a capital
defect in the denouement
and "Prove the thing feasible.
"There is a sketchy
sense of such alterations
"as I think necessary."
His advice was to render the
incestuous act an accident
the result of the
countess's supposed jealousy
over her husband, in other words
to replicate the plot
of "The Fatal Discovery"
that contrived but stage worthy drama.
Thank you.
(applause)
- Thank you very much Jean.
We're gonna have lots to
talk about the stage ability
verses unstage ability I
can see in the talkback.
Next it's my pleasure
to introduce Al Coppola,
who is an associate professor
of English at John Jay College
in the CUNY system and
he's also the past chair
of the Columbia University seminar
in 18th century European culture.
His first book "The Theater of Experiment,
Staging Natural Philosophy
in 18th Century Britain"
is a critical study of
science in and as performance.
His current book project,
"Enlightenment Visibilities"
studies the 18th century
innovations that structure
21st century modernity by bringing
previously unimaginable
or imperceptible phenomena
into the domain of
perception and knowledge.
Now I would like to say that
I added in the lightning
in last night's show just for Al
because he's going to be
talking to us about lightning.
Let's just call it serendipity.
So his title for us today is
"Spectacles of Science and Superstition."
- Thank you so very
much to Cindy and to Misty
and to everyone that put this together
and for welcoming in someone who I guess
I can't really call myself a Walpolian.
I'm actually not even
gonna be talking so much
about literature either today
because what I want to think about is
sort of the scientific
contexts that are circulating
that I think we want to put on the table.
I want us to think about
"The Mysterious Mother"
for a range of reasons and certainly
one of the most important
ones surely must be
how this notorious drama
helped shape that emergent form
of the Gothic mode.
What do we get when we situate this play
alongside Walpole's
endlessly read "The Castle of Otranto"
as the twin headwaters of
the gothic's murky flow.
What was the context in the
catalyst for this play's
mysterious monstrous birth in 1768
and what can it teach us about the sources
and textures and meanings of form?
So I'd like us to think about what happens
to the supernatural in
Walpole's gothic vision
when we move from "Otranto"
to "The Mysterious Mother."
Certainly we've got the gloomy,
moldering castle a motif
and there's certainly
a has an abiding sense
that the places and spaces
of this story are accursed.
But in "the Mysterious
Mother" we find no examples
of the hallucinatory literalism
we had in "Otranto."
I'm thinking that
preposterous giant helmet
so mad fastly and insistently real
that it kills a young heir dead
and even serves as a
temporary holding cell
for a suspected malfactor.
That helmet is a deliberate
and weirdly material signal
that Otronto is truly haunted.
The gothic tale is
straight-up supernatural.
Past crimes of usurpation and cruelty
do not merely persist in guilty memory.
Those wrongs are real and the very palace
is haunted by supernatural
agents that avenge them
in fulfillment of what it seemed like
a cryptically figurative prophecy.
Turns out the warning, the
castle on lordship of Otranto
shall pass from the present family
whenever the real owner
should be grown too large
to inhabit it, that was absurdly literal.
Cue the supernatural, exit
Manfred running from a giant
but "The Mysterious Mother"
is quite different.
In fact it posits a
deliberately anti supernatural
version of the Gothic.
No Giants stalk these ancient halls,
no skeletons rattle their bones,
talking portraits are right out.
The castle and heirs of
Narbonne are cursed for sure
but there's no evidence
that supernatural agents are to blame.
In fact the thunderstorm
that we did have to cut
to make it stageable plays
such an important role
in act two, scene two
that so terrifies the
denizens of the place.
It triggers a pitched battle
about the very possibility
of supernatural agency
and it becomes an opportunity for Walpole
to explicitly disavow it.
So we begin with Florian and Edmund
meeting the procession
of orphaned children
making a pilgrimage to the count's grave
on the anniversary of his sudden death.
When Florian overhears
the scheming priest Martin
encourage the children's
superstitious belief
that the count is haunting the shrine,
the blunt-talking soldier confronts him.
His friend Edmund might
kneel to omnipotence,
Florian says but that does not mean
"Each gossips dream, each
village fable domineers
"in turn his brains distempered nerves."
And it's at this point
that the storm comes on.
Walpole stage directions read,
"violent storm of thunder and lightning."
But this triggers a debate
about its proper interpretation.
Martin declaims, "Will
this convince thee.
"Where's the gossips dream,
the village fable now?
"Hear Heaven's own voice
condemn impiety,"
and Florian giving as good
as he gets respond back,
"Hear Heaven's own voice
condemn imposture."
"What says the storm?"
asked Florian in the scene quite pointedly.
And I'd say that Walpole is
asking it to attend very closely
to this question.
"Pronounces it for thee or me?"
Asks "do none dispute
within the compass of its bolt
but we? Is the same loud-voiced oracle
"definitive for fifty various brawls?
"Or but a shock of clouds to all but us?"
In fact Walpole has
placed in Florian's mouth
a compelling argument
against superstitious belief
and the credulous or knavish narcissism
that would feed it and would assume that
some storm is some sign from God.
Now it's a compelling argument but I'd add
we need to remember it's a
very very timely argument
for the 1760s were the decade that saw
an intense interest in
the nature of electricity
and in particular,
its relationship to lightning and thunder.
So Benjamin Franklin of
course published experiments
and observations on electricity in 1751
which theorized that the electrical fluid
that natural philosophers
had been experimenting with
via electrostatic
generators and Leyden jars
was the same phenomena responsible
for the awesome destructive
power of electrical storms.
Many Naturals accepted
Franklin's hypothesis
but even into the 1760s,
more than a few prominent dissenters
resisted Franklin's claims
in scientific circles
following the lead of the
Abbé Nollet who spoke out
against identifying
lightning with electricity.
However the 1760s drew
the curtain on what became
the second act of this
scientific controversy.
While most conceded
lightning was electricity,
there was a decades-long
dispute that was erupted here
about the efficacy of lightning rods.
Perhaps what was the defining
scientific matter of concern
in the later 18th
century and in this sense
I'm thinking about Bruno Latour's
thinking about matters of concern
as in cautious distinction
of matters of fact.
Since 1752, Franklin had been advocating
and installing pointed lightning rods
to draw down electrical
charges from threatening clouds
in order to lower the
likelihood and decrease
the deadliness of lightning strikes.
Now many English
naturalist remain skeptical
of their efficacy at all while others
through their support
behind Benjamin Watson
who advocated round-tip
lightning rods and in fact
the first lightning
rods were only installed
in England in 1762 just two years later
and just two years later an
article by Benjamin Wilson
alleged that they would in
fact prove more dangerous
by making lightning strikes more likely.
So while this philosophical dispute raged
in the learned press and in the pages
of the Philosophical Transactions,
the newspapers of the day
devoted a remarkable degree of attention
to reports of lightning
and electrical storms.
The 16th of August 1764 edition
of the "St. James Chronicle"
reported "A severe storm
of thunder and lightning
"recently experienced in Boston,"
"the heavens appeared
in one continual blaze
as each rooftop lightning
called down the celestial fire
in a what appeared to be a
dazzling array of patterns"
to the eyewitness.
Just one mighty strike
did damage it was reported
but there were no points erected
within a half mile of this house
and so as you can infer this
and so many of the other reports
to appear in the popular
press and "Gentleman's Magazine"
during these years explicitly advocated
for the erection of lightning rods
but that's not to say they all did.
The 11th of April 1765
"Gazetteer and New Advertiser
published an account from
a maritime correspondent
who reported that, "During a violent storm
"of thunder lightning and wind,
"a luminous body surrounded
the spindle at their masthead
"which appeared to be
a perfect body of fire.
"May it not be conjectured,"
that's the editor,
"that aren't spindles at
the mastheads of ships
"often attract the lightning
that would otherwise escape."
Yet that same newspaper a few months later
published a harrowing account
penned by Thomas Erskine
who is the master of the
Royal Navy frigate Tartar
about an electrical storm
that he went through
off the coast of Florida.
After first having been
struck by lightning
on the quarterdeck,
Erskine was brought below
for medical attention.
However, as he wrote, he,
"Had not been down a minute
"when we heard a noise equal
to all the guns of the ship
"exploding at once.
"The shock of lightning or electricity
"destroyed in an instant
the mainmast, main topmast,
"main top gallant mast, tearing
them in a million pieces,
"large splinters flying
all around the ship
"from many yards distant.
"The sails rent in as
many pieces or threads,
"streams of electric fire
rushing at the same time
"down to the bottom of the ship.
"In short never was
anything more tremendous."
I think this helps contextualize
the way Walpole concludes his storm scene.
The children come running back on stage
interrupting the men's
debate by carrying news
of an offstage conflagration.
"Oh a storm so dreadful,"
cries one orphan.
"Some demon rides in the air."
Martin cynically goading them on
asked if none had the
courage to face the fiend
and one reports, "I winked
and I saw the lightning
"burst the monument.
"The shield of arms shivered to splinters.
"Ere I could repeat an Ave Maria
down with a hideous crash
"the cross came tumbling."
Walpole didn't have to
embellish this scene.
We know that one of the
reasons why lightning rods
were such a crucial matter of concern,
a genuine article of debate is that
they drew down as it were,
lingering superstitions about the causes
of sublime natural events
like lightning storms
while the question of the efficacy
and the proper design of lightning rods
was being debated by the learned
on both sides of the Atlantic,
people were still being
electrocuted to death
in shockingly high numbers
due to the persistence
of pre-modern beliefs
that lightning was an act of God
and a sign of his displeasure.
And as Trent Mitchell discusses
in a really great article
in 18th-century studies in 1998,
according to many contemporaries
the only true safeguards
from this providential instrument
were a full trust in God
and a hearty repentance to
move God's heavy judgment.
So clergy not unlike the
clergy we see in the play
might be using instances of lightning
to extend their moral
influence and authority
over the flock, as Martin does
but it also meant they
actually have to do something
when storm's threatened.
And so generally this meant
the ringing of church bells
but of course this exposed the faithful
to terrible deaths by electrocution
if they were up in the Campanile
yanking on wet bell pulls
when lightning struck.
Now this is not some gothic
prehistoric superstition.
One report issued in Munich
found that over a 33 year period
386 lightning strikes hit bell towers
and they resulted in 103 fatalities.
This report was published in 1784.
No wonder that the "Lloyds
Evening Post" of May 1768,
the same year Walpole penned
"The Mysterious Mother,"
felt the need to publish a long extract
from the history of the
Royal Academy of Paris
on how to "Preserve
one's self from Thunder."
TLDR don't hunt under
trees and for God's sake
don't ring any bells. And I think
there are a number of plausible reasons
why Walpole's version of the
Gothic shifts in this way
from "The Castle of Otranto"
to "The Mysterious Mother."
Chief among them I think is
as we've been discussing Walpole's
obstinate retention of that incest plot
and his insistence that this
play must be at a heart,
investigation how the countess copes
with the unimaginable guilt of an act
of a truly diseased imagination.
He wants to focus it
on internal struggles.
Too much attention paid
to supernatural agents
would distract from his
analysis of morbid psychology.
Besides Walpole may have quite sensibly
been writing against the
formal material constraints
of the theater.
It is a bit of an open question
whether he really thought
this could be staged
but I'm convinced it for a while there
they thought this might
have might have worked.
One can certainly more readily narrate
an electrical storm offstage
than one can represent a
giant falling cask on stage.
But I do think the play's
curious treatment of electricity
in particular is
deliberate for it registers
and draws cultural force from
the ambiguity and suspicion
that gathers around lightning
as this kind of crucial matter of concern.
These electrical debates
revealed a certain
persistence of pre enlightened
gothic credulity and while
Walpole's protagonists
reject Martin's supernatural
trappings outright
And I think they speak in the voice
we're supposed to
acknowledge and agree with,
the very popularity of this Gothic mode
that Walpole initiates exploits
even as it exercises these
pre-modern fears and longings
and it gives voice and
form to a wider suspicion
of the enlightenment project
and discourses of science
And it's that wider suspicion
of the discourses of science
and the enlightenment project
that I think is in the air in 1768.
That's the same year as Joseph Wright's
remarkable portrait experiment
on a bird in an air-pump
and if you're familiar with that,
the center of the portrait
is that the sphinx-like gaze
of Wright's scientist who sort
of stares blankly at us
with his hand on the
stopcock of that air-pump
about to let the air back in
to bring that bird back to life
but were caught in that
split-second moment
of anticipation and fear.
I feel like "The Mysterious Mother"
as much as his sphinx-like
gaze seems to be asking us
we're moderns aren't we or
if we've never been modern
or we aren't modern yet or we
can't ever hope to be modern,
what a thrill it is
to be caught in the play of these forces.
Thank you.
(applause)
- Thank you so much.
Fascinating.
All right moving right along.
Our next paper will
come from Judith Hawley
who is a professor of
18th century literature
in the Department of
English Royal Holloway,
University of London.
Her research interests include
the history of amateur
performance, hooray,
as well as publishing on
Laurence Sterne, encyclopedias,
Siamese twins and Grub Street,
she has audited various
18th century texts.
Currently she's writing a group biography
of Pope Swift and the Scribblers Club.
She's a regular speaker on the radio,
most recently appearing on a
discussion of the gin craze
in "On Our Time" BBC Radio four.
Her title for us today
is "The Beautiful
Negligence of a Gentleman,
Horace Walpole and Amateur Theatricals."
- Thank you very much Misty.
I'm very happy to add to
this wonderful thank fest
we've been having here.
I don't want to name people
what I really want to thank
everybody who's been involved
in making this thing happen.
it's been oops, it disappeared.
I shouldn't try to do two things at once.
It's there, it's good.
Also a little bit of a
modesty trooper Walpolian
modesty troop which means
it's not really modest at all
but I will be using some of the
same examples and quotations
that you have heard already
and I'll try to cut a few as I go
but I don't want to mess up the paper
in the act of trying not to say something
that you've heard from
one of our other speakers.
Anyway, here we go.
It's generally assumed
that it was because of its
sensational subject matter
that Walpole's Mysterious Mother
did not have a public
performance in his day
but I think the situation
is more complex than that.
It's not just the incest plot.
Both Walpole's feelings
about professional theater
and public reactions to his
play were not clear-cut.
For example the "Monthly Review"
considered it no less proper
for representation than Otways "Orphan"
which included a triple suicide.
Moreover David Worrall has
discovered that it was adapted
and performed at Thomas
Dibden's in Surrey theater
admittedly not till 1821,
thus after Walpole's death.
He calculates it must have been
seen by about 16,000 people
who didn't write, didn't
complain to the newspapers
or otherwise signal their disappropriation
of public dramatization in central London
of one of society's most
supposedly sequestered vices.
Now the context in 1821 as David
definitely demonstrates is very
different from that of 1768.
But nonetheless I do think
that Walpole at some point
and in some part of himself
did envisage a public performance
and wrote a comic epilogue
for Kitty Clive to read
which we've heard
but he did say, "But I'm not so sure
"that she'd like to speak it."
But the responses of his
even his close circle
to this story of illicit
passion quickly made him realize
that for the sake of his reputation,
he must suppress the play.
Within weeks of completing it, Walpole
admitted to his old school
friend George Montagu
in April 1768, he did not
think it would do for the stage.
And I'm going to come
back to that quotation
because I think that
idea of what he means by
would it do for the stages
is a little bit tricky.
So I want to consider why Walpole
did not think it would do for the stage
and what that might tell
us about theatrical culture
in the second half of the 18th century.
I'm going to focus on his
aesthetic and social motivation
more than the psychosexual ones.
Other critics have read the plot of incest
and maternal desire in
"The Mysterious Mother," as
Walpole's way of both representing
and concealing homosexual feelings.
Jill Campbell for example has demonstrated
very deftly how that can be done
and how one needs to be
careful about doing it.
But I'm going to consider
"The Mysterious Mother"
from it the theater history point of view
and also to consider theater history
from a different vantage point.
"The Mysterious Mother" was never performed
in London's patent theaters
but performance in Drury Lane,
Covent Garden, Haymarket was
not the only option available
to playwrights in the 18th century.
So if it wouldn't do for the stage,
what kind of venue was it suited to?
What kind of work does
Walpole think it was
and what might that tell
us about theatrical culture
in the second half of the 18th century?
Is it a closet drama?
Now we've heard something
about this already today.
Closet dramas written to be read silently
or out loud in small
groups were fairly common
in the early modern period
and enjoyed increasing
popularity in the Romantic era
when the taste for melodrama,
pantomime and comedy
were driving serious verse
drama from the public stage
or that was the perception.
Walpole's play predates Joanna Baillie's
great revival of the closet
drama by about 30 years
and he's such a a pioneer in
inventing the gothic novel,
inventing the gothic play.
Is he also inventing a new
form of closet theater.
Get a sense of what early
modern closet drama was like
and why it might appeal to Walpole.
I'm going to quote Marta Strazynski
who says that in the early modern period
it was more common among communities
which felt isolated
from mainstream culture.
She describes the former's part
of a larger cultural matrix
in which closed spaces, selective
interpretive communities
and political dissent are aligned.
It is notoriously difficult
to define closet drama.
Jacqueline Mulholland
points out quite recently
that the term has a range of meanings
from written to be read rather
than performed to unperformable
either because not meeting the aesthetic
or moral standards of the time
or simply being too bad to be performed.
Catherine Burroughs has
challenged the firmness
of the distinction
between closet and stage
especially if that distinction is figured
in terms of a binary
opposition between the closet
as private, domestic,
literary, mental and feminine
and the theater as public,
spectacular, performative,
physical and masculine.
Walpole is nothing if not
a straddler of borders.
The first outing of the play
was a kind of closeted
performance however defined.
On the 17th of April
1768 Walpole and Conway
read the play to an audience
comprising Lady Aylesbury,
Lady Littleton and Miss Rich.
And I don't think their
responses to that are recorded
but it would be so nice
to hear what they said.
We know that he had 50 copies of the play
printed at Strawberry Hill
press for private circulation
and that some of these books went astray,
were circulated in manuscripts
and that he couldn't control
what people did with his play
or where it went.
About 18 months after it was printed,
Walpole learned that Montagu
and a group of male friends,
the boys, had found his
play at Montagu's house
and insisted on leaving
off gambling and drinking
to read it through together.
He was not pleased.
I beg you would keep
it under lock and key.
It is not at all food for the public.
So even Walpole thought
this limited kind of public
performance would not do
and seem to think that
the privileged owners
should keep it under lock and key.
00:54:45,123 --> 00:54:49,960
And he restricted access to
even some of his close friends
who thought that they should
have had a copy sooner.
Horace Mann didn't see
a copy of it until 1779
when his nephew brought
it out to him in Florence
and the nephew are supposedly
learnt it by heart on the way.
Mann was delighted with it
and thought it perfect
for closeted performance
as his nephew proved by
performing an impromptu iteration
and what Paul Baines has described
as a pleasantly gothic setting.
I won't read it but I'll
move on just to mention also
a performance that we've
several times discussed
over the course of the day.
The wonderful sort of
delicious illicit performance
that occurred in the palace in 1786
when Frances Burney chanced upon the copy
that Lord Harcourt had.
Lord Harcourt lent his
copy to Queen Caroline,
she saw it and said, "Oh
this is by my friend Horace.
"I think we'll read this aloud,"
invited people around and
this little growing horror
when they realized quite
what they were reading.
Nonetheless Walpole did
not completely rule out
public performance. In the
1768 letter to Montagu
which I quoted earlier after admitting
that he did not think it
would do for the stage,
he added, "Though I wish to see acted."
In 1769 the letter to Montagu
is carefully balanced.
"It is not at all food for the public,
at least not until I am
food for worms, good Percy"
alluding to Shakespeare.
Thus he does leave open the possibility
of a posthumous performance.
And he does seem
to have consulted his friend William Mason
on how to prepare it for the stage.
Some of us looked at Mason's
mark top copy earlier today
and one thing that should be said is that
Mason and Walpole seem
to be an exchanging plays
backwards and forwards, asking
each other to advise them.
So Mason's advice on how
to edit and make acceptable
Mysterious Mother comes
immediately after Walpole
had just written to him about two comedies
Mason had sent him and Walpole told Mason
one of them's good yeah,
we should get this put on
but do it anonymously.
The other one not so good.
So it's part of this sort
of economy of circulation
and advising and we'll
Walpole was quite involved
with dealing with the
professionals in the theater
and getting things put
on and helping Jephson
is someone we've already
heard about as well.
I'll come back to him.
Lots of advice backwards and
forwards about revisions,
dealing with theater managers.
Publicly he thanked Mason.
He said, "Wonderful you're a genius.
"I don't know how you did it,"
but privately Walpole
rejected Mason's suggestions
because he felt they
totally destroyed his object
which was to exhibit a character
who's sincere penitence
was not degraded by superstitious bigotry
as he wrote on the back of the letter.
He thanked him profusely for it
but taking such pains with this play for
as Mr. Gray could tell you
I cannot correct myself.
Walpole's attitude to correction
is connected I suggest
to his attitude to the
possibilities for public performance
and we can see this more clearly
in another letter to Mason.
This time about works produced
at the Strawberry Hill Press.
He defiantly declared, "I
hope future edition mongers
"will say of those at Strawberry Hill,
"they have all the beautiful
negligence of a gentleman."
He liked the typos.
He didn't want them corrected.
As a scholar and an editor,
my first thought is that
Walpole is boasting of a
kind of culpable carelessness
and neglect a lack of
regard for what is correct.
But I think he has in
mind the original meaning
of the term negligence.
Careless indifference as
in appearance or dress
or in literary or artistic style.
Later freedom from
artificiality or restraint
also an instance of this now rare.
So it's freedom that he's after.
Freedom to experiment originality
that he's praising in
himself. But specifically
an indifference to professional standards,
an indifference which grants
him freedom from restraint.
Crucially it's a freedom
granted him by his class status.
Whether discussing the moral character
of the countess in his play
or the correct printing of
characters at [indistinct],
Walpole expresses an aristocratic disdain
for the vulgarity of professionals.
In the 1769 letter to
Montagu I quoted earlier,
when Walpole argue that
he did not want his play
performed during his lifetime,
he didn't mention his moral reputation
rather he complained about
the current standards
of the professional theater.
"Nay, it is not an age to encourage anybody
that has the least vanity to step forth.
There's a total extinction of all tastes,
our authors are vulgar, gross, illiberal.
The theater swarms with
wretched translations
and ballad operas and we have nothing new
but improving abuse.
I blushed at Paris when
the papers came over
crowned with ribaldry
or with Garrick's insufferable
nonsense about Shakespeare.
Garrick's prologues and
epilogues are as bad
as his pindarics and pantomimes."
He was on polite terms with Garrick
but he repeatedly
bad-mouthed him in private.
So he didn't want his play to be mangled
by professional performers.
That's one of the worries I wouldn't deny
that the incest is affected too
but he was really worried
about what would happen
if his play was staged by professionals.
And he wasn't the only one dissatisfied
about the behavior of actors and audience
in the patent theaters.
"The Mysterious Mother"
I suggests can be seen
as part of a larger
process which was occurring
at the margins of professional theater
challenging its economic
and cultural dominance.
David Worrall, Jane Moody and others
have documented the attack
mounted against the
monopolies the patent theaters
by the rambunctious minor
theaters in the late 18th century.
To counter this threat
the patent theater staged
more spectacular
productions and pantomimes
to clawback the audience. And in response
to the perceived increase in the vulgarity
both of the productions
and of the audiences
at these ever bigger theaters
at Covent Garden and Drury Lane,
members of the social elite
including a number of
Walpole's inner circle
took to staging their
own private theatricals
in which they could control
both the repertoire and the audience,
admitting only people they had vetted.
Private theatricals became fashionable
both because of their exclusivity
and because of the performativity.
The people who acted yes
they presumed you had a ball.
Participating in culture is a major factor
of the rise of private theatricals
but it's another factor is
this aristocratic desire
to control what they perform
and who gets to see it.
And these private theatricals
became such a fixture
in the social calendar
that they were announced in
the newspapers, in the listing.
So all the major London
newspapers which would say
what's on at Covent Garden,
what's on at Drury Lane,
they'd then say what
Mrs. Hobart was doing.
What was performing in
the Richmond House Theater
they are listed on the front page
and newspapers often carry examples
with their prologues and epilogues,
plot summaries, reviews, a list
of members of the audience.
It's like those accounts of
big parties and premieres
where all the guests are listed.
So the names of the
guests are as important
as the names of the performers
And Walpole collected a
lot of this information
in his massive collection
of plays of George III.
There's one volume of
prologues and epilogues
and its newspaper cuttings and
it indiscriminately includes
both the patent theaters
and the private theaters.
He cuts and pastes the two
kinds of documents together.
And a number of his letters give accounts
of attending private theatricals.
And a play that sort of pseudo play
that's been mentioned a
couple of times today,
"The Dear Witches" this sort
of satire based on Macbeth,
it's a surprise theatrical.
So it's not just a mock play
but it's a mock private
theatrical performance
of a version of Macbeth.
So the sense of what a
private theatrical is
informs his sense of
the theater generally.
So the play text the
whole performance culture,
the audience culture.
Now for Walpole these elite
amateurs not only embodied
rather than performed their roles,
they also embodied taste.
The upper classes were
well schooled in music,
dancing in the fine
arts and some were keen
to stretch these accomplishments further.
Mostly they adopted the
repertoire at the patent theaters
producing a succession of
comedies and cut down Shakespeare.
Some especially those in Walpole's circle
wrote their own plays.
Walpole's cousin Henry Seymour Conway
performed his own adaptation
of "False Appearances"
at Richmond House in 1788 and 1789.
His daughter and Walpole's
heiress Anne Damer
acted Mary Berry's "Fashionable Friends"
at Strawberry Hill in 1801.
The most prolific amateur
playwright was Walpole's friend,
Elizabeth Craven the
Margravine of Ansbach
who wrote, produced and acted
in a succession of plays
in her gothic Star Theatre at
Brandenburg House Hammersmith
between about 1790 and 1805.
Some of these scripts written
by amateur aristocratic playwrights
made it to the public theaters.
Craven's comedy "The Miniature Picture"
had a run of three nights
at Drury Lane in 1780
and Conway's "False Appearances" enjoyed
a run of six nights at
Drury Lane in April 1789
and Walpole complained
that the play was adapted
to get cheap laughs.
So I think Walpole had no
opposition in principle
to the social elites
writing for the public.
He himself had an afterpiece
"Nature Will Prevail,"
performed regularly at the
Little Theater Hay Market
between 1778 and 1788.
For him it was a question
of aesthetic quality,
a quality measured by his taste.
In a letter to Hannah Moore,
he refers to a skirmish in print
about two noble playwrights
The Dukes of Newcastle and Buckingham.
A gentleman essayist
asked him why it was more ridiculous
in the Duke of Newcastle
to write his two comedies
than the Duke of Buckingham
to write "The Rehearsal."
"Alas I know but one reason which is
"that it is less ridiculous
to write one excellent comedy
"than two very bad ones.
"Peace be with such answerers."
This dispute was prompted by
an account of these two Dukes
and at the ancestors of the essayist William Belsham
included by Walpole in his catalog
"The Royal and Noble Authors of England,"
an ever-expanding labor of love,
first printed at Strawberry
Hill press in 1758
and augmented and revised
in various reissues.
In work such as his "Catalog
at the Royal and Noble
authors of England" he builds a case
with contribution of the
upper classes to culture
as producers as well as
consumers of literature.
He was not so blinded by his class.
He could not see the faults of
his royal and noble authors.
He frequently gerdes himself up to produce
his most withering wit at their expense.
For example after describing
the writings of William
and Margaret Cavendish
the Duke and Duchess of
Newcastle he declares,
what a picture of foolish nobility
was this stately poetic couple
retired to their own little domain
and intoxicating one another
with circumstantial flattery
on what was consequence to
no mortal but themselves.
Well people in stained glass houses
should not throw the
first stone Mr. Walpole.
Yet he values this category
of writers for two reasons.
The first is that there
are not career writers.
Their authorship was
secondary to or sometimes
the product of their service to the state.
The second is that their
independence from the market
in his view made them better able
to establish standards
of tastes and excellence.
Walpole resisted public performance
because he deplored the
current state of the theater.
Writing to Robert Jephson and 1777
about this gentleman
authors new play Battaglia
Walpole declared, "If I were the author,
"I should be very sorry to
have my tragedy murdered
"perhaps miscarry and to give your work
"strong, worthy performers is
like sacrificing a daughter
"to her husband of bad character."
Actors were not the only problem.
Walpole also directed
blame at theater managers
who because of their
enslavement to convention
and dependence on the
box office were unwilling
to foster truly original
writing on the stage.
Among the reasons he
gave to Montagu in 1768
for not putting his Mysterious
Mother on the stage,
Walpole fulminated, "Nor am
I disposed to expose myself
"to that jackanapes Garrick
who lets nothing appear
"but his own wretched stuff
"or that of creatures still duller,
"who suffer him to alter
their pieces as he pleases."
He encouraged Jephson to
produce his "Count of Narbonne"
which we've heard of already,
not at Covent Garden
where it was staged in 1781
but in his hometown of Dublin
where he could oversee rehearsals.
Managers will take
liberties and often curtail
necessary speeches so
as to produce nonsense.
Take warning David.
Methinks it is unkind to send a child
of which you have so
much reason to be proud
to a foundling hospital.
So lots and lots of
metaphors of work has baby,
of murder and so on.
So for Walpole the beautiful
negligence of a gentleman
represented a freedom from rules
and the liberty to experiment.
Repeatedly he objected the way
the French neoclassical unities of time,
place and action were
imposed on British drama.
I'll skip this quotation.
It's a lovely quotation about cats.
In his pocketbook but I
don't need some move on.
I want to get a cat into
every lecture I give.
Usually show a photograph
of my own cat at some point.
Anyway moving swiftly on.
So we've heard about the
PostScript to the 1781,
printing "The Mysterious Mother."
I'll just pick out a few
phrases, he talked about
people being enslaved to rules,
he prefers an ample attitude of thought
and pursuance of which is introduce
some novelty on our stage.
He boasts that the cast of the whole play
unlike any other that I'm acquainted with.
In particular the character
the countess is certainly new.
Novelty, originality, freedom.
These are his watch words.
Mostly Walpole asserts
these freedoms for himself.
But I think that he hints that
by exercising such freedoms,
gentlemen might raise standards
of tastes and reform in the theater.
Now I just want to end
by turning to Cynthia
that some of my impetus
for this work on Walpole
has come from her wonderful article
on Walpole and Female Genius
where she talks about how
Walpole's championing of lady Di
who did those incredible
suit water drawings.
He was interested in a
number of women geniuses
many of whom were on that sort of fringes
a respectability or
downright unrespectable
and he valued their lack of training,
their leisure deeds and their independence
from the marketplace and
that's a lot of his emphasis
in championing them was to
oppose academic standards.
The standards of the Royal Academy.
And I would like to suggest
that his attitude to the theater
was very similar.
He's insisting on developing
a kind of an amateur culture
in the theater as well as an
amateur culture in the arts.
Although we don't
expect necessarily to find
the avant-garde in the amateur sphere,
I do think that the private theatricals
might allow us to rethink the significance
of the emergence of the
professional theater
and the kind of complexity
that it entails.
Thank you very much.
(applause)
- Thank you and one quick
PSA before we go on.
If you saw me pulling
my cell phone out here,
I promise it wasn't texting my friends.
If you are interested in
promoting any of the pictures,
ideas or images that you've been a part of
these last two days, you can tweet it
and there's a hashtag Walpolooza
and so if you hashtag it
then maybe you can see
what others saw and
captured and reflected on.
All right, wonderful.
Well I get to introduce my new colleague
and fellow script
conspirator, David Worrall
who gave us that fantastic
cut of "The Mysterious Mother"
and chiseled a playable shorter piece
out of Walpole's longer work.
David is emeritus professor of English
at Nottingham Trent University England.
He's published widely on
long 18th century theater
including theatric revolution
and celebrity performance and reception.
He's held grants, fellowships
and has more plaudits
than we have time left today
but these include the Leverhulme Trust,
the Arts and Humanities Research Council
and The Lewis Walpole Library Fellowship.
And today he is going to
speak to us about the play
under the title, "'I beg you would
keep it under lock and key':
the mystery of the 1821
'Mysterious Mother' performances."
- So again if I can say
it's been an excellent
opportunity to come here
that invitation from Cindy
and the Walpole library
and of course having been involved in it
right from the start with Misty.
So it seems like along time ago
I was presented the
opportunity to do these things
and so these things and
so probably talking about
in fact is some of the things
which have been discussed earlier.
So I hope that as I'm the last speaker,
this would be light but not lightweight.
That's my kind of aim really.
But to go back to look at
it the other way around.
So really what I'm talking
about is not the way in which
"The Mysterious Mother"
was controlled by Walpole
but really how it escapes.
So its escape from control
really is the story
that I have to tell in kind of two halves.
So this is really I
guess so September 1769
is the first read-through
of "The Mysterious Mother"
and I'll show you on the next slide
but these are the personnel involved
in George Montagu's house.
"I've had such a houseful
schoolboys for a week
that they're noise still
tingles in my ears.
Thank God their holidays
are over and they are gone."
So George Osborne, Colonel Burgoyne
which is not the one who'd
surrendered at Saratoga
because I thought there'd
be an American link
but there's not.
Captain Bosco and Young
Osborn, a parson of theirs
and one of their squires
came all upon me on a
sudden and live riotously
from morning to night.
So that's the context
of how they then do this read through.
"The boys found your tragedy
"The Mysterious Mother"
and the boys as they
are they had no patience
till they finished it and
we read the acts amongst us
for my lungs could not
Pritchard it through.
They left off quinze gambling and claret
and were the Florian's of your play,
the churchmen indeed look grave,
but they threw him his Ten
Commandments and a bottle of port
and amused themselves without.
They would have got it by heart however,
a few similes they have retained
and a cap with one another
some of the lines that struck the most."
So what we've got there is so first of all
they kind of captured a character
which is the Florian one
so that's the first
reception history if you like
of Florian as a character. And of course
what he's saying is that
they've learned by heart
some of the speeches and of course
they seem to have read through it.
So it's in that kind of riotous context.
So already within a year
"The Mysterious Mother"
is kind of out there
amongst that very mixed
group of individuals
who seem not least completely
fully at ease with it.
They're having a very good time.
So there's none of these kind
of darker aspects about incest
or gothic or any of the things
which we may associate with it.
They associate the play
and they're the first people to read it
and to act or read it through
a staged reading perhaps.
They begin the reception
characteristics of that drama
and so we tend to have forgotten this.
It seems to me that the private sit
in that private theatrical mode in fact
the play has escaped and
it's become something
which of course Horace has no control over
and so there of course we get
him after the horse has bolted
as you may think is
the thing. And of course
that's my point really is
that these famous lines
about keeping it under lock and key.
One needs to look back
at what they have actually
done with the text
and in fact you know although he says
to keep it under lock and key
in fact it has already escaped.
There wasn't a lock in the
first place if you'd like
and so that really gives
the prompt for this way
in which that first
audience and players in it
are completely ease with this play is that
this is how this culture
is receiving this play
as something that they can
enjoy as an entertainment
and something which they can learn
and that they are comfortable with.
So unless it's some other version
of "The Mysterious Mother" that they've got
but I don't think there's
any evidence for that.
That's what we know about that.
And so the thing that I
came across some years ago
is the venue of the first performance
which is at the Surrey Theatre,
one of the minor or illegitimate theaters
on the south side of the Thames.
And that's really important
it's on the south side of the
Thames because what it meant
is that they didn't have
to send a licensing copy
to the Lord Chamberlain because
the Lord Chamberlain's remit
only ran in Westminster on
the North side of the Thames.
So we don't have a text, manuscript text
for the performance that
they did for that reason
because it escapes through that way.
So the manager of it is Thomas Dibdin.
So he's an important
character because he's the one
who's probably done the first cut of it
as I'll begin to show.
So that's the theater previously
known as the Royal Circus
and it's part of that
expansion in the minor
or the illegitimate theaters
that begins around 1818
with the opening of
Waterloo Bridge in 1818
because from then when
Waterloo Bridge opens up.
You can walk from Covent
Garden and Drury Lane
across to the other side of the river
As you may know the present
Old Vic is the Old Coburg
is the Royal Coburg theater.
That's the same site
and these two the Surrey
and the present-day Old Vic, we'll call it
the Royal Coburg Theatre, were
in competition with each other.
So not only do you have this
opening up a new theaters
on the South side of the Thames
but also elements of competition.
So it's a very vigorous
community of theaters,
not a community. They
kind of hated each other.
But trying to find new material
and that this is new
material that they found.
Now when I published the essay,
I didn't have an image
included in the essay
of the post of the playbill
and I only refound it recently
in the bowels of my computer.
So that's I think the next exhibit.
So it's a photograph of microfilm.
So because there were 10 performances,
there were 10 of these.
Of course I'm only showing
you the first one there
and I'm just gonna blow that up a bit.
And so you can see that
there's no kind of ambiguity about that.
The serious melodramatic
romance in three acts
founded on a tragic play written
by the late Horace Walpole
Earl of Orford and now
presented for the first time
as it says never acted
before under the title
of Narbonne Castle or
the Mysterious Mother.
There is no ambiguity
about what that play is
and that is exactly what the play is.
You see that as it goes on to say
a noble author, maybe he
refers to the Byron preface
to Marino Faliero.
So that's just kind of cue if you like
and he goes on to say "there
are however in the fable
circumstances of a dreadfully terrific,
of so dreadfully terrific in nature
that most [indistinct] material
alteration in its construction
has been thought necessary.
Now first of all because it's a theater
on the South side of the Thames,
they have to put music in.
Now that's not a choice.
It's not an elective choice.
That is because the theaters
on the South side of the Thames
and the theaters outside of
Covent Garden and Drury Lane
if they have to do musicalized versions.
So the patentees at Covent
Garden and Drury Lane
who have the monopoly on
speech protect their monopoly
by oppressing the minor
theaters and certainly
in Dibdin's case he had spies
around from the patentees
to see what he was doing.
They were trying to close
him down essentially
and they were trying to
close down the others.
So because but the patentees thought that
they were playing spoken drama,
so this is a musicalized
version of the play.
Contracted it to three acts,
what I want to emphasize is that
this is not something
that they elected to do.
This was something because of
the regulatory circumstances
that they had to do and so probably
the reason why it contracts the three acts
is because once you've added the music
which they needed to keep their license
of course the play, the whole
play takes a lot more time
and of course he would have seen as I saw
that it's eminently cuttable anyway
and so that is what he was doing there
and the other thing that I
found out only the other day
since I've been here
where I hadn't realized
that the time have brought
out the Journal article.
In 1819 Dibdin had tried
to lease Drury Lane
and so Farmington the
Walpole library in 2017
bought some new manuscripts which exposed
and which go through his
attempts to take over
the lease of Drury Lane which he failed.
What would have happened to Dibdin
is that he'd raised from a linen merchant
in the Strand [indistinct]
warehouse 10,000 pounds
to pay for the lease plus Drury Lane
wanted him to pay 3000 pounds
to refurbish the theater.
So although the new theater,
the newly refurbished Drury
Lane had opened in 1812, 1813.
By the time that he comes
to take over the lease
or try to take over the lease,
it had fallen into disrepair
despite Edmund Kean and all of that.
Anyway to cut a long story
short it came to sealed bids
but he was not there
when the bids were opened
and so according to Dibdin,
he felt that he'd been cheated
that somebody at the last stage
had opened up a sealed bid
and then put in a 100 pounds more
and so he had every reason
to be antagonistic against Drury Lane.
The reason I think he
chooses to do it is that
it's a spoiling attempt on Marino Falieri
which Drury Lane is bringing out.
The circumstances of that play is that
the publisher tries to bring an injunction
against Drury Lane to
stop them staging the play
Byron of course as you know
isn't in the country anyway.
The license from the Lord Chamberlain
comes back to Drury Lane
but the servants don't tell
the manager that the
license is in the playhouse
and so that afternoon they
couldn't stage it anyway
so even though the
injunction hasn't been heard,
Drury Lane in other words are themselves
playing a dangerous game. And
so what you've got really
is a way in which all these
theaters are competing
in underhand ways against each other.
And so in a way "The Mysterious Mother"
is part of that attempt by
Dibdin to get his own back
on Drury Lane where he had
these really awful experiences.
But this is my main point really.
It is a three-act version.
We can think of good reasons
why it should be a three-act version.
It's also musicalized because
of the regulatory environment.
It's not something that
he would have chosen
to do himself perhaps and so
that's how that came about there.
And so what I've tried to do meanwhile
and this is really the end piece really
is that this is the first
actress to play the countess.
So this actress is the one
who establishes the role
in theater history.
Miss Margaret Taylor and
that's an image of her
and as you see there,
that's Miss Margaret Taylor
of the Surrey theater and there she is.
She's referred to there
Jacqueline Countess of Narbonne.
"The Mysterious Mother"
is played by Miss Taylor
and there we have that actress
located with this Surrey theater there.
And so I was trying to do some
calculations the other day
and if you accept my interpretation
that first 1769 read-through
would also have had
somebody playing the countess.
So all those male guys who
were in that house that night
again they're very
comfortable with playing
a big female role.
This makes by my calculation
because you've got them
so we capped the
schoolboys as we call them.
So that's the first countess.
We don't know who that one would have been
and then we've got that
one, that's number two
then there's Glasgow production in 2001
and so Georgina here
is the fourth countess.
And that's the end of my talk.
Thanks very much.
(applause)
- Thanks so much everyone.
I would like to invite
our speakers up here.
(mumbles)
Is there anyone who would like
to lead off the questioning?
We have once again the handheld mics
and we do ask that you wait
until the microphone gets to you
because we're recording
this for posterity.
The countess has a question.
(laughs)
- [Georgina] Thank you.
It looks to me as though
that first production
must have been a huge amount of fun
with people sharing the part of Pritchard.
Just maybe passing it around them
and probably competing to
see who could do her best
perhaps moving it as well.
And the other thing I wanted to ask you,
perhaps I should have asked at home
but we didn't get time is the
adaptations made to the script
the way that they kind of
parts have been blinged up
so that the the plot, the gothic
plot is kind of foreground.
You've got the confesser
and this kind of stuff.
- Yes, the spectral monk.
(mumbles)
- [Female] Have you got any sense
or is there any script at all,
anything that suggests
what they would might have been reviews?
- There are a few reviews
that I've been able to find.
Again you know there are no complaints.
Nobody complaints--lines
up outside the theater
and so it was reviewed but
there are not many reviews
and generally you know
because it plays for 10 nights
it's just a perfectly
reasonably good success story
for that particular playhouse.
So it's just kind of average.
It's nothing special in their run
of productions at that time.
I mean Dipdin was doing
more experimental drama.
I think the one that I worked on before
is called something like "The Fall of Troy"
where he manages to refer to to the Sun
and the Norwich Union insurance companies
because they're obviously
sponsoring him to do that
so it's that kind of theater if you like
so it's a very kind of normal
but it's not Covent Garden
or Drury Lane type of thing.
- I would just say it's so tantalizing
you get these little traces
that seem to speak so big
and there's a spectral
monk in that production
it seems like pretty much
I said about the play
in 1768 is not applying
and it would presumably be
sort of a part and parcel
with at that point,
a robust sort of Gothic drama tradition
and the question that I
wouldn't be able answer
as to what extent is the stage craft
and you know special effects that mark
the you know the patent theaters.
To what extent was that
replicable at Surrey.
- The playbill does also suggest
that the plot has been censored.
(mumbles)
- How did you arrive at that?
- Hang on one second.
Let's get Dale.
Dale we're going to get you.
- [Dale] There are however
in its public circumstances
of so dreadful terrific in nature
that most material alteration
in its a construction
has been thought necessary which is
hope has been affected without
injury either to the poetry
or the intense and powerful interest
which pervades the romantic. What I sense
- Carry on.
You can walk into the trap.
(laughs)
(mumbles)
What would be the point in saying
this is "The Mysterious Mother" by Walpole
if it's circulating in the print culture
which is what everybody's
been talking about
so that everybody knows it's
circulated in the print culture
so it is a book everybody's
been saying which is known
and then you don't do it the
way that people have read it
and so what you've got
really because the playbill
is a mediation between the
performance and the audience.
What you've run into the trap is,
this is viewer caution advised.
So that's the come on,
oh you want to go and see that play
because there's something going on in it.
So would you have taken out the incest?
Why produce that play?
- [Male] I didn't mean
they're being taken out
but I think it would have
been a version of the play
closer to Mason's--
- It's referring to
some sort of alteration
and materially around the incest.
- Which is the music, right?
That's a material alteration.
- I don't see any evidence
of that whatsover.
It's been tidied up.
Exactly and I agree entirely
that it's drawing attention
to the scandalous nature of the play
while perhaps avoiding
obscenity but it seems like
that's the draw.
Like you know there's
something like intensely dark
and frightening about the incest plot
we're going to stage this in
such a way that's legal
and at the same time
we're going to remind you
about everything that's so
treacherous about this play.
- Kind of alcohol free wine.
It's what you're saying.
- The follow up question
in but then also a comment.
In the reviews that you say you've seen,
does anybody mentioned that
the incest is still there?
- No.
- They don't indicate either way?
- They're having a good time
just as the school boys were.
That's my point is that and
they don't say anything.
- Then the other question is precisely
what is the nature of the
scandal? Because we've heard
that there are all these incest things
and I think it's it Emma Clery.
I think Marcie talks about
this in one of her articles
that one of the most scandalous
things about the play
is the Mysterious Mother's obvious lust.
That's more scandalous
than incest in itself.
It's the desiring mother,
the actively desiring mother
who kind of rapes her son
and that's the real scandal.
Well that's more of a scandal than incest.
- [Male] It's part of it.
(mumbles)
It's sexuality in one way or another.
- And representing it is very
different from reading it.
It's more powerful and so
reading it is a little safer.
- I'm gonna take moderator
and director's privilege here
and say that in this
work of representation
we're back to some of the problems
that Judith has set
out. And in the question
that both Marcie and Jean
brought to the floor,
did Walpole know this was unperformable
and I would just take that question apart
and make a distinction
between performable and public
and I think that that's where
we can kind of find our way in
and think about his imagined,
amateur and private audiences
as a place where it is
indeed quite performable
and the intimacy of those gatherings
as we discovered in rehearsal
with a very small group
elicits a lot of reaction.
The ick and the gag reflexes.
The sort of engagement
with production itself
that's possible, that has something to do
with scale of audience and
the intimacy of the gathering.
So I think that's where we
can kind of take back apart
the question about the
performability of it
into the possibility of private
and amateur performance.
- [Georgina] I will just add something,
it's not that it's retrospective.
If you don't see anything going
on between those two people,
they report it so it's not
as offensive as actually
I mean it's kind of French
in a way or a Greek even
so you only see her
confessing to what she's done.
And that there is physical
contact went in our production
he caught her and you could say that
he helped her stab
herself which is phallic
but you wouldn't need to do that
in a physical representation.
You could do an awful lot with music
which might help make
it a lot shorter as well
and perhaps maybe a little
bit more entertaining
because we did discover that some of it
was a little bit funny.
So there are two things
going on there as well
and I think if you cut the incest out
I mean you've got a very big problem
with the whole play really.
I mean that's the whole point.
- [Male] But look at the title.
(laughs)
- The title alludes to
Jephson's "The Castle of Narbonne"
which is already a sanitized version
that only has name from...
So it alludes to that with a bit sort
couple of spoonfuls more of
Mysterious Mother in that.
- One of the reviewers
refers to it mistitled
it as "The Countess of Narbonne"
which is really quite interesting.
- Well and as we discovered too in a cut,
music can do a great deal of work for you.
- [Male] Could I ask this
is for Judith really.
I was interested in I
really enjoyed your paper,
the ties between the
way the Walpole controls
the circulation of text
using the story on press
and describe and decides very carefully
whether it's published under his own name
or published separately
but nothing resembling
or not published at
and how some things are printed
but not so fitted at all
and same way with the
your ideas with the play
is just how that's contained
to an amateur private group
as we've said.
It would have helped the argument
if he would have been involved
in any sort of production
but he actually isn't but it
does time to the other point
which is the whole gentility business.
If you were doing an amateur
theatrical by gentlemen
there's that great line about how gentleman
will react better or something like that.
So there's all that class thing.
- It's in my text,
but I might not have read it out.
So it makes it quite clear
that that there is no record
of a private theatrical performance of it.
And I don't have any record
of Walpole himself on stage
but he certainly attends
private theatricals quite a lot
and the way in which the
audience and the actors
are drawn from the same class
in a way that the
performance we saw yesterday.
What we saw yesterday
was kind of an elite,
amateur dramatic performance, wasn't it?
Where you're the intellectual
aristocracy out there
and you're the same kind of people
from roughly the same group, aren't we?
So that sort of circularity,
the mirror world
of the audience [indistinct].
So he participates in private
theatricals in that way
but it wasn't performed.
I think he probably did
feel it never anyway
so there's that. On the printing of texts,
you know much more about how
the printing press worked
and the audience worked but I do think
there's a way in which as you say
sort of answered your own question,
the choice of who he circulates things to,
the amount of attention he
gives to the authorship.
Some works are the author
is puffed up enormously
or the press has its own agency,
the press speaks, the press
takes on a life of its own
so there's something much more personal
non-commercial I think is
part of the point there.
These are things given as gifts,
as part of a culture of exchange
not a marketplace culture.
And definitely I think the
point about the actors,
I forgot to read a passage
just very very briefly.
A short quotation from his description
of a performance with the Hobart's in it
and I was quite surprised that he has
this very favorable
account of Mrs. Hobart.
You might know Albania Hobart
from Gilray's satirical prints
where he basically he
draws a complete circle
and puts a tiny little circle
on top, that's her head.
She was a woman of substantial means.
And he describes a 1782 production
of "Mirth is all in the
wrong" at Ham Common:
"Mrs. Hobart played
admirably and most genteely
which was very refreshing
as one never sees anything
like a woman of fashion on the stage.
The eldest Miss Hobart
so lovely and so modest
was not acting, she was the thing itself."
So there's a sense that
there's authenticity of it
and you get this also and
Lady Craven's plays that
if you're acting a tragedy
or you're acting a drama
of public importance you have those people
who play those roles in real life,
playing the role of King
the Earl of so and so
the Duke of so and so.
So this again is that less
there is a certain kind of authenticity
and a certain kind of
campness combined in this
to bring in sort of Marcie's point about
this of the complexity the double nature
of Walpole's attitude to most things.
I hope that encapsulates that a bit.
There were a number of complaints about
what the private theatricals
sort of take another slightly different view of it.
There's a number of examples
of people praising they very fine
and authentic performance.
There are also complaints
that the aristocrats
were taking bread from their
professional actors mouths.
That they're taking their jobs
and also stealing their audiences.
So when productions were done in London
during the theatrical season,
Sheridan basically closed down
one of the privates
theaters, The Picnic Society
because they were taking his audience.
- Jill.
- [Jill] Thank you so
much for these papers.
They're just so informative
and thought-provoking
and I have two kind of
two unrelated things
that I wanted to say or ask about.
Such a revelatory basic
point about C"astle of Otranto"
versus the world of "The Mysterious Mother"
that there aren't
supernatural forces there.
And I think about the
the Radcliff monk, Lewis
kind of struggle and so on
the rationalized supernatural.
But I was just thinking
looking at it through
the light that you shed on it
and also thinking about Nicole
Garret's paper this morning
that the countess is read
as suspect and transgressive
because she doesn't believe
in the supernatural.
She's accused of that and then
she knows and we eventually
know that no that's not the
nature of her crime at all.
She has this this terrible past crime sin
that she has committed and I
was just playing with the sense
that Walpole was doing
something transgressive perhaps
in the terms of the play
in not extending faith
to the supernatural.
I don't know how the
sexual crime and belief
or disbelief in the supernatural
and I'll just throw out
while I have the mic
at my unrelated so just
to David and maybe others,
Marcie or Julia could comment.
I was just really struck with that letter
from George Montagu which
keeps talking about the boys.
You gave the birth dates.
They're not boys.
- It's a kind of homo
social group, isn't it
- [Jill] In terms of
this a different aspect
of the spontaneous reach
staged reading there.
The kind of fantasy on
juvenileness of the group.
So just throw those out for anyone.
- To respond to your first point,
it's kind of remarkable that
in these two texts by Walpole
you see this sort of fundamental
tension in the Gothic.
We want to sort of explore this.
There's a fun little disagreement about
to what extent should we assume
that there's supernatural force.
Do we problematize that
or do we play with it?
And I don't know I mean would have read
the countess's problem is
not that she is a heretic
by refusing to believe
in the supernatural,
or refusing to believe in the
magical power of confession
to enact a miracle to
wipe your soul clean.
I guess I didn't think of it that way.
I thought it was just a
matter of her just resisting
the authority that
she'd have to give over.
So she knows as soon as
she speaks her truth,
she's basically going to be manipulated,
subject to blackmail but I think
that is an interesting point
and they certainly accuse her
of not being faithful in that way.
It's interesting that that position
is put in the mouths of fools and children.
And it's put in the mouths
of you know explicitly
cynical manipulative priests.
You read the play and you're
kind of supposed to take
this sort of you know
demystified perspective on this.
Of course it's not really
you know a supernatural event
and we ought to...
There are way more interesting
sort of gothic themes to explore
rather than is this world full of ghosts
and vengeful gods and things like that.
I guess in my thinking about
it this sort of engaged
in this sort of lightning controversy,
and kind of a larger sort of
enthusiasm but also suspicion
of this enlightenment science project
and in particular the way
in which it comes home,
there's so much of interest
in doing one's own experiments.
It becomes itself a
kind of private theater
sort of performance discourse that folks
sort of participate in.
I guess I was thinking that Walpole
is sort of picking up a similar ambiguity.
Why are folks doing this?
Are they really learning
some substantial truths
about the universe?
Are we really sort of engaged
in the project enlightenment,
are we just thrilling to this stuff
and kind of enjoying the sort of
confusion delight and surprise.
I feel like it's kind of a similar menu
of ambiguous pleasures that you partake
of those science performances as you would
from this gothic performance.
- So just to what you
were saying Jill before,
I think what's really interesting is that
what we see in the reception of the play
where it's non reception or whatever
is a range of sociable theaters.
Some are more professional,
some are more private
and some can be more spontaneous or not
and they are all it's
quite an interesting range
and I'm thinking myself of
Abigail Williams' recent book
about sociable reading
where she talks about
reading drama as well.
I think that that's an
element of literary reception
that we have a lot more work
to do on capturing the range.
So that's that.
- Nicole, I think we have time.
- [Nicole] Thank you for
these really rich papers.
My question is for Jeanne
and I was wondering,
I remember reading Clery's
article on "The Mysterious Mother"
or her contribution to the edited volume
and she says or she claims
that audiences at the time
would have noticed these resonances
with earlier incest plays
and wouldn't have been shocked by it
and she particularly
calls attention to plays
such as Dryden's collaboration
from Nathaniel Lee the 1679,
Adaptation of Oedipus but she doesn't give
any kind of textural sense of
actual evidence of reception
which would indicate that readers
were reading those plays together.
So I was wondering if you come
across any evidence of that.
- I don't know about
reading the plays together.
Certainly just the responses for example
to "Phaedra and Hippolytus"
when would see more
complaints about Phaedra
and her desires in contrast to say
what they saw in Aureng-zebe
or in earlier plays
in Greek versions of say the
Phaedra story or Oedipus even.
So that they were aware of other plays
and I'm not sure in some
cases from having read them
in other cases from having seen them
because the response to
"Phaedra and Hippolyta"
is a really very much response
to seeing something staged
and spoken about.
Walpole actually when
he's talking about Phaedra
and I think he's talking about
Phaedra talking to the chorus
in the Greek play is talking about
how illogical it is.
The responses that say
Gildon had to Smith's play
are about staging it and
hearing Phaedra vocalize
the fact that she desires
her son and that's...
So I think that there is
an awareness of this body.
I mean certainly nobody could
avoid knowing "The Orphan"
was one of the hugely popular plays
when you get to "The Old Manor House,"
of course the character
of the orphan is Monimia
so I think that in general that
these were the popular ones
were just lurking in people's minds.
I wouldn't give that
claim say to "Don Sebastian"
or necessarily as you
got further along to say
"Phaedra and Hippolytus"
although it was staged
multiple times in the 1750s.
So it's really hard
unless you can trace down
going through a journal
or finding letters,
just have somebody as well I saw this
and it made me think of
seeing such and such a play.
So I don't know if that helps.
- I'm afraid we're out of time
but I want to thank everyone
from the Lewis Walpole library
who has made this possible,
everyone from the Yale
Center for British Art
especially Dean up in the back
and thank you all for taking
a chance on a crazy experiment
to stage this play which I
think we've learned a great deal
and thanks to our panelists and everyone
for their participation.
Have a great afternoon.
(applause)
(light music)